[MUSIC]
Thanks for being here, and thanks for
the kind introduction, Jim.
I wasn't planing to talk too much
about Unilever, if you don't mind.
He said enough already about it,
so that's probably where it stops.
But flying in this morning to come here,
I had to take an early plane,
and I was sitting there at
the airport in Los Angeles,
and I overheard three people talking.
And I know it's very impolite to listen
to people talking at an airport, but
I know you all do, so I'm not.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm not ashamed to share
the story with you.
But I quickly discovered that there was
an engineer, an economist, and a doctor.
And they were bragging,
and the doctor said,
hey, I have the oldest
profession in the world.
And the others said, why is this?
He said, well,
you go to the Book of Genesis.
Eve came out of the the rib from Adam,
and Adam came out of the ribs of Eve or
whoever.
Both of them survived,
that was the first successful operation,
doctors have the oldest profession.
And the engineer said, I don't think so.
Because when there was chaos,
we created the universe, and
to make order out of chaos,
you have to be an engineer.
So engineers have the oldest profession.
And the economist said, I don't think so,
because who created chaos
in the first place?
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I think that describes a little
bit about what I want to talk about today,
who created chaos in the first place?
But before I do that, let me first
tell you how pleased I am to be
here in this Conradin von
Gugelberg Memorial Lecture.
We were just talking with some of
the people who have known him and
studied with him in the class of 87, but
he seem to have been a remarkable person,
and frankly,
a little bit ahead of his time.
As I said then,
I would love to met him, but
it's certainly an honor to be part of
his life indirectly by recognizing him.
And doing that in a school like Stanford,
obviously, is a wonderful opportunity.
We have a great institution here.
Undoubtedly, I will call my mother
today and tell her I was at Stanford,
and she'll be very proud.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But you also have a very progressive,
and we were talking that vision towards
what the role of the education should be,
and the people that you are producing
here for tomorrow's wealth.
He'd been very instrumental, as Jim said,
to work on the high common stock
issues around deforestation, etc.
And we don't have the academic
world actively involved,
and I don't think we can solve so
many of the world's problems.
We had a chance this morning,
with a tremendous group of professors and
faculty and PhD students and others, to
talk a little bit about the challenges of
in the supply chain,
which are not all that obvious.
And to think about that together,
the more you talk about it means
that these issues are solvable, but
we all need to contribute our
own individual parts to this.
And as a university, I think more than
ever, showing your leadership in the area
of sustainability will place you very
well, because the future issues that we
need to solve are obviously the challenges
of climate and energy or water or
biodiversity or natural capital and
many of the other things.
The students that are here,
I think the skill sets that we need
to learn to be successful in life,
undoubtedly, many of them are going
to be the same as we've always had.
We need hardworking people, a certain
level of intelligence, integrity,
all these things are not going to change.
But increasingly,
we need to have some other skill sets to
be successful in this world, and
clearly, many people struggle with that.
Otherwise, I believe we would
have solved already some
of the challenges that are out there.
But to be a good business person,
you need to know as much in the future,
in my opinion, about sustainability
as you know about sales.
So you need to know as much about climate
change as you do about cash flow, or
you need to know as much about
international development as you do about
business development.
It really requires a broader
vision if you want to manage these
challenges that we know we
are seeing everyday in this world.
The first thing to start on
a little bit of a positive note,
I think it's actually
a great time to be here.
If you look at the last 15 years, the
world has actually come quite a long way.
We've seen the effects of
globalization actually benefiting many
people as we can see that the spread
of some of these ideals of democracy or
the opportunities that are offered by an
increasingly integrated global economy and
an interdependent world has undoubtedly
lifted many people out of poverty.
In fact, in the last few decades,
more people have been lifted out of
poverty than any time in human history.
More people are going to school
than any time in human history.
More people have access to clean
drinking water or sanitation.
And yes, it's also true that
more women are actually
participating in the global
economy than ever.
In fact, the original goals that we
set in 2000 for the global agenda,
which were called
the Millennial Development Goals,
had as a simple objective to halve
the number of people living in poverty
over the 15-year period
from the year 2000 to 2015.
And in fact, we have achieved that.
We have achieved that, and
we should be proud about that.
This is a healthier and
wealthier world than at any time.
And but
at the same time, I have to take a step
back a little bit after these 15 years.
And it reminds me a little bit of Dickens
who wrote in the 1870s this book,
The Tale of Two Cities.
At that time,
he was talking about Paris and London.
I'm spending most of my time in London.
But his book starts with, it was the best
of times, it was the worst of times, and
I think we're a little bit
in that situation right now.
We've lifted enormous
people out of poverty,
we also have still challenges
that need to be solved.
And many of these challenges, actually,
I think we became fully aware of
that in the crisis in 2007-2008.
Some people said it's a financial crisis,
and some people said it's a governmental
crisis, then it became economic crisis,
and we're still recuperating from that.
In fact, it was the worst crisis on record
since the Great Depression in the 20s.
And I think it made us realize,
I've always found, by the way,
that this was more of a crisis
of morality than anything else.
But it made us realize that the system
we had created had certainly lifted so
many people out of poverty, but
it wasn't quite sustainable.
It came at an enormous cost, a high
level of private or government debt.
An enormous level of overconsumption, and
frankly, leaving too many people behind.
I've always said that in any system
where too many people feel that
they're not participating or
are being left behind,
that system will ultimately rebel against
itself just like a cancer in a body.
And you've seen that happen increasingly,
so
the question is have we learned
anything since this crisis?
I hope the answer would be affirmative,
but if you look at the hot numbers,
you have to really ask yourself questions.
The debt that caused this crisis, by the
way in economic system that was very much
around, we asked the Saudis to pump
the oil, we asked the Chinese to produce
the plastic, and
we asked the Americans to consume.
That's basically what we are doing
in a very simplistic way.
And you'd think we would have learned form
that now that we are 8 years further or
9 years further, but
the global debt actually has
gone up by another 57 trillion.
That's 40% more global debt.
Obviously, all these things have
played a role for it, basically,
in Europe and the US Companies,
actually, you see the same behavior.
In the future of companies, more being
given back on special dividends and
share buy-backs and the financial side,
because of this abundancy of capital.
But very limited amounts of money
are entering in the real economy,
and you get over-consumption.
I think we're still on this
linear consumption pass,
only 10% of the packaging,
for example, gets re-used.
90% ends up in landfills and
unfortunately more and more in the oceans.
That's not going to last either.
So on the consumption pattern,
we still haven't moved to a circular
consumption pattern at
the speed that is required.
In fact you take the top 1.2
billion people in this world
that to which we all belong,
believe it or not.
But the top 1.2 billion consume
75% of the worlds resources and
the bottom 1 billion, only 1%.
But I can assure you, if you are on the
bottom, you all aspire to live like us and
the numbers don't add up anymore.
We're living way beyond the limits
of our planetary boundaries and
climate change obviously is one
of the effects that we see.
And then you think we left
too many people behind.
Well, we're again a little bit further and
frankly in the next,
the [INAUDIBLE] since the crisis,
the Gini Coefficient, in all countries
in the world has actually gone up.
The only country that is an exception
I believe is Ecuador, by memory, but
the rest,
we've actually increased the gap.
And now it's 62 people in this world
that have the same net wealth as
the bottom 95%.
In fact, the top 1% in the world has
the same wealth as the bottom 99%.
We've created, really,
a system that is not sustainable,
but we've certainly not made it better.
And one of the key effects that you
see from this is climate change.
In fact, the World Bank's Jim Kim
estimates that we have just passed the 1
degree towards the 2 degrees which
is about the maximum that everybody
thinks this world can handle before
the consequences become dire.
Lots of people are starting to
talk now about 1.5 degrees.
In fact, scientists are finding out,
it's the bleeding of the coral reefs for
example,above 1.5 degrees,
the coral reefs are gone.
Scientifically now,
basically well established.
And if that happens,
you'd put the likelihood of about
a billion people at risk again.
But interestingly, Jim Kim from
the World Bank issued a report fairly
recently that we stay on
the current trajectory
then about 100 million more
people will fall into poverty.
Climate change, as I've said many times,
is actually a human development agenda,
it's the poor that suffer.
When you add Hurricane Sandy or
other things in the US,
I have sons living in New York.
They had a great time climbing the stairs.
They didn't have to go to the gym.
They saw some people a little bit more
than they were watching television.
But in the end of the day,
it was in a few weeks you were back
with the resilience you built up but
the people in Haiti and others,
they were pushed back another few years.
Climate change Is a development agenda
issue, more than anything else.
14 of the last 15 years have
been the warmest on record.
So California has not
been excluded from this.
I think Jerry Brown has been a fairly
outspoken governor in this state.
And the water shortages that you have, and
the extensions of the limitations of water
you can use as a good example of that.
In fact the IMF estimates that the real
cost of climate change to the global
economy, already today if you include
everything, which is air pollution,
in China 1.8 million people a year
lose their lives to air pollution.
If you count all the externalities in
there, they're estimating that there is
about $5.3 trillion already now
in costs of actually not acting.
Whereas just looking at
the Loman school of economics,
I gather one of your competitors to some
extent, that said that climate change,
actually the economic losses
could go to about $27 trillion,
that’s about 20% of the world’s assets,
that’s quite a lot.
And the sustainable accounting
standard boards have in fact,
if you look in the US,
93% of the US equities would actually
be at risk because of climate change.
And it’s not just
the financial side of that,
WWF was calculating that in the last,
since the 70s we
have lost about 50% of our mammals,
reptiles, our birds.
So it's a question a little bit of,
when is it our turn, in my opinion,
if we don't take any actions without
being a doom state scenario.
I was reading a book from who
Hubert Ribs was a Canadian philosopher.
And Hubert Reeves said something
that stuck to me when I read this.
He said, man is the most insane species.
He worships an invisible God and
destroys a feasible nature,
not realizing that the feasible nature he
destroys is the invisible God he worships.
And that is about what we
are doing right now, and
that's obviously not a path
rate that is sustainable.
So I was very glad to see 2015
hopefully being a watershed year,
because in 2015,
two historic things happened.
First of all,
the signing of the Sustainable
Development Goals in September in the UN.
With all the followup from the millennial
development goals covering the next
15 years, where 193 countries in
the world went together and said for
the next 15 years we have an opportunity
to irreversibly eradicate poverty.
Irreversibly eradicate poverty in
a more sustainable and equitable way.
Out of that came 17 goals.
Goal number 1, obviously,
poverty alleviation.
Goal number 2, food security.
Goal number 5, gender equality.
Goal number 6, water sanitation.
Goal number 16, governments.
Goal number 17, partnerships.
16 goals, that if we would work all
these goals, we could indeed do that.
And the first test of these sustainable
development goals came in December,
last year in Paris.
It was the famous Cup 21.
The Cup 21 where all the countries in the
world began, about 190 countries submitted
their intended nationally
determined commitments.
What they thought they could do to
stem the tide of climate change.
We were on a four degree trajectory, and
lo and behold in Paris with the agreement.
We've actually bent that curve.
The agreement covers all countries, four
times more than the Kyoto Protocol, and
it was on a voluntary basis, you propose.
Just adding up what was proposed.
No back sliding, cannot go back, five year
review, $100 billion a year financing
to move forward obviously and
help the poor countries.
A pretty good agreement
as a starting point.
Obviously we have discovered that we
cannot wait till the end of the century to
tackle climate change and
now we have to work on accelerating it.
But the base has been late.
So I'm actually very pleased that, for
the first time in history, we could
be the generation, if you want to.
And especially the young people here,
that solve poverty.
Which is a noble goal to go for by itself,
but also ensure that future generations
don't have to deal anymore with
the effects of climate change.
I was very pleased a few weeks
ago in New York where I was
present when 175 member state countries
actually rectified the Paris agreement.
We need 55% of the countries, 55% of the
carbon emission to make that go into law.
But interesting to see the US right now,
the Chinese and some others are actually
trying to push this agenda forward to
ensure a more rapid implementation.
Now this agenda which is
an enormous agenda for
humanity, zero property,
zero carbon emission.
I don't think any business person
would set such an audacious goal for
his own business.
And certainly not if you tell him or
her that's in the next 15 years more or
less That the thing needs to happen.
So we won't get there if we
don't work all together, and
business has an enormous role to play.
Which is the only thing really
I want to leave you with,
that more businesses need to start
taking a higher level of responsibility
to be part of that solution.
After all, there is no business
case in enduring poverty.
I've discover that a long time ago,
even in our company which is fortunate
enough to be in 190 countries or
reach 2 billion consumers a day.
We have to be sure that this
is a more inclusive society.
An interesting statistic,
not to bother you with that, but
the world spends 9.7 trillion
a year on violence and
war preventions and spendings on actually
having these things 9.7 trillion.
If we would just take that money,
which is three times higher
than the development that
gentlemen I am talking about.
We could wipe out all the debt in
the emerging markets with that.
And we could give some of the money
still that is left to Europe to
start stabilizing the European
monetary system like we're longer to.
This is just a little free from my home
base so that we get a little bit for
this, but
this is what we are currently doing.
This world has become reactive and
spends behind the symptoms of the results
instead of attacking the cause.
You see the same in other areas by the
way, healthcare's a good example where you
have an enormous epidemic coming
up of diabetes two with obesity.
And we end up spending all
the money treating it instead of
going to prevention.
This is very much what we're doing
in the global economy as well.
Now you won't solve this development
agenda if you don't get business involved.
It's very simple,
the development agenda as I mentioned,
cost about two to $3 trillion
a year which by the way is a pimple
on the global economy of
100 to $110 trillion.
It's actually a shame that we have to talk
and knock on people's doors and, as we
know, there's enough money that is going
around just have to put it to better use.
But the overseas development aid from
all the governments in the world
has come down now to about $160 billion.
And the pressure is more
downwards than upwards with all
these attempts to reduce
these government deficits.
So you need to use that
relatively small amount of money
to unlock the private sector financing to
make this development agenda come alive.
Now another statistic that would show you
why the private sector should be enforced
is because if you look in basically
the emerging markets which will be 80% of
the world population very soon, you'll
have the private sector be 60% of the GDP.
About 80% of the financial flow and
90% of the job creation.
So if you don't involve
the private sector,
it's very hard to see how you can
actually then solve these things.
And then the bigger companies have to
be obviously even more so involved.
The top thousand companies in this world
have about 50% of the world market cap.
And not only that, they actually
have done, in terms of revenue,
you're talking about $35 trillion.
So if you don't get these
big companies involved,
you don't get to that tipping point,
and we're obviously one of those.
So yes, there is a self-interest to
make these economies,function, but
it is also enormous opportunity for
business,
obviously if they understand this and
be part of this.
Not being part of it,
I think risks the very essence of your
business model in the first place.
Now business has many responsibilities.
I always like to quote Viktor Frankl who
wrote his book Man's Search For Meaning.
Viktor Frankl was
a survivor of Nazi Germany.
And in his book, he wrote that when they
built the Statue of Liberty on
the east coast of the United States,
they forgot to build the statue of
responsibility on the west coast.
There is no liberty
without responsibility.
So if you are a company of our size, or if
you are a country like the US or others,
then you need to have that responsibility
to actively be part of that solution.
For business it obviously means
responsibilities towards human rights,
towards paying our fair tax in
the places that we operate,
towards being part of fighting this
enormous disease of corruption
that is still everywhere in
many places in the world.
And I think an increasing amount of
businesses start to understand that,
enough for sure not, but
an increasing amount is.
Business starts to
understand also increasingly
that not acting might actually
have a higher cost than acting.
I think we're actually
at that point right now,
that the cost of inaction is
higher than the cost of action.
And you see that again if you look at
some of these numbers of climate change.
But you look at food security, this is
still a world where about 800 million
people go to bed hungry every night not
even knowing if they wake up the next day.
It's totally unexplainable if
you don't at the same time
realize that we're wasting 30 to 40%
of the food that we are producing.
As if we don't care, the food that we
waste is about $800 billion every year.
Forget the effects on climate change and
all the other things that's just
a small detail that comes with it.
But we're wasting $800 billion in food
while it actually only takes 80 billion to
feed these people that go to bed hungry.
Isn't that an equation that
humanity should be able to solve?
And yet, we are unable on the G7 or the
G20 to get food security on the agenda.
That's, in fact,
as far as I'm concerned, a scandal.
Now, equally there are enormous
opportunities in this development agenda.
Opportunities for business for
all businesses, if they really understand
that, just investing equally in this
world and women as we do in men.
Access to financing,
education, land price,
which unfortunately is not the case
in the majority of the country still,
would unlocked the global
economy by $28 trillion.
Any one dollar in nutrition,
we still have a hundred 60 million
stunted children being born every year and
it could be your child or mine.
Just investing $1 gives
a $17 back to society.
Investing $1 in water and
sanitation has a payback of $6.
Any business would love to have
these returns on their investments.
And yet, why don't we do that.
If we have such enormous opportunity's
why can we not get the world together and
do this.
I think the first main element
that is clearly missing is trust.
It's an easy word, trust.
What we are running currently is a society
where everybody mistrust's each other.
If you look at the Edelman survey which
is published every year at the time of
the World Economic Forum, you will
see that trust in governments is at
an all-time low, trust in business,
trust in CEOs even lower.
And as a result of that,
obviously many people have given up.
I think one of the extremes that you see
this year in your political cycle in this
country, which is a great amusement
to all of us living abroad.
And I'm glad I live abroad.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Watching it from a distance, but
it is really, people are fed up.
They've all become against anything
because the established order is clearly
not attacking the issues that need
to be attacked with a maturity and
sense of morality that is needed.
And that is the same by the way
in many other countries.
It just kept, doesn't get as much share
of voice, as obviously the US media does.
But trust is very low and
trust in business is even lower as I said.
And that's not surprising, because we've
seen an enormous amounts of scandals.
And normally I could take
the Financial Times of the day and
I can open everyday of Financial Times,
and as one or another company that gets
caught because they refuse to invest in
safety and the well and the goals for.
They refuse to invest in
the safety of the workers and
a factory collapses in Bangladesh.
Or they manipulate LIBOR or
foreign exchange rates, or
they start to tinker with the emissions
standards of their engines.
And the list goes on, the list goes on.
And in this age of transparency,
what companies need to understand is
that there really isn't
any place to hide anymore.
I don't think that these issues are more
or less than they were before, but
they are certainly more
transparent than they were before.
That I can tell you.
So companies need to take notice of that
and be sure that the way they operate is
transparent, and take responsibility for
that if we want to build that trust.
Trust can only come from transparency.
Transparency builds trust and
trust is needed to build prosperity.
And any time these companies don't
behave responsibly, you see over and
over that about 30 to 40% of
their market kept disappears.
So increasingly, not surprisingly it's
interesting also to the financial market
that want to know that what they
are investing is responsible investing.
The other thing we need is
obviously transparency, as I said,
that goes with trust.
I don't think you can build
trust without that transparency.
We are publishing far more data now
as a company than we've ever done in
the history of mankind, I believe,
and we will continue to do that.
Because by showing what we do, by giving
access to many people, we can build that.
The other thing that is needed
is a different business model.
If you want to solve all these issues
like climate change, or food security, or
poverty alleviation, or access to
clean drinking water, or education,
if you want to, you cannot be
victim to the quarterly reporting.
This market and this wealth has become
incredibly short term, incredibly myopic,
and many companies, unfortunately, would
forego doing the right decisions long
term if it affects their quarterly
profits versus market guidance.
It's become very myopic.
And not surprisingly, the average length
of a publicly traded company in the US now
has come down to 17 years.
The average tenure of
a CEO is now 4.5 years.
In that short cycle, these longer term
issues that really are important for
all of us are not getting
the attention that they need.
So you need different business models,
and even when I became CEO we
stopped doing quarterly reporting.
We stopped giving guidance.
We moved our compensation
systems to the long term.
But more importantly,
we developed business models that
really are firmly ingrained in
the principle of partnerships.
It was Einstein who said the definition of
insanity is to do the same thing over and
over again and expect different results.
That's not going to work anymore.
We've come so far, if we now really
want to snap out of this and
create this better wealth for
everybody, we have to become adults and
start working at
a different level as well.
And that different level has to
come via trust, as I mentioned, but
certainly a different form
of partnership as well.
It's a partnership more than just you and
I working together because the two of us
can do more than each of us individually.
It's first and foremost a partnership for
the common good.
Where we put the interests of others ahead
of our own, knowing that by doing so
we will actually be better
off in the longer term.
If we get that higher level of
partnership, of moral morality,
if you want to, I think we can
solve any of the world's problems.
We don't need more PhDs, in due respect,
or missions to Mars to find the answer.
For most of these issues of the
development agenda, we have the answer.
And frankly, increasingly we
see others becoming aware of
the enormous potentials or
the downside of risks if we don't act.
I personally would only want to invest
in companies that create a better future
where I can retire in or
my children can live in.
So we see people becoming
much more conscious
of how they use the power of their wallet.
Millennials are the best example of that.
In fact, this is the first year that the
millennials in the US will have the same
number of voting power
as the baby boomers.
Unfortunately, they're not
as politically engaged
because they've been turned off
a little bit by what is happening.
But it's the same now.
In 2020, which is not that far off,
we have significantly more
millennials as voting power.
And these people are far
more purpose driven,
they are far more conscious of how
they put their dollars to use, and
hopefully will be a big wave of
change that will benefit us all.
But the financial evidence is also there.
I personally don't believe that the thing
will move at the speed that we need
to move it if we don't get
the financial market involved.
Unfortunately, if you want to,
it is still a global economy that
very heavily depends on that.
And the interesting thing is
that most of the studies now
actually show that companies that
are more transparent obviously
take risks away from the financial
market and have a lower cost of capital.
It also shows that you get
better operational performance.
Companies that think
about climate change or
some if these issues also make their
whole value chain more resilient.
And then not surprisingly, the stock price
performance, everything else being equal,
is actually better off, companies that
are more responsible in this market.
What Unilever has done with their Unilever
Sustainable Living Plan, that Jim briefly
referred to, is actually create a business
model where we totally decouple our growth
from environmental impact and
increase our overall social impact.
But the difference from CSR and staying
in your own shop if you want to, or
making it only part of your company is
that we fully integrate this in all we do.
It is in fact our business model, and
we take responsibility of
the total value chain.
You cannot solve issues if you just
stay in your own narrow little box and
work inside it.
If in our case, you're in the food
business, you have to take
responsibility from the farm to the fork
and all the issues that are in between.
The issue of malnutrition or stunting,
the issues of climate smart agriculture,
the issues of food waste, the issues of
creating jobs for small holder farmers,
the issue of deforestation, half of it
driven by the enormous demand of food.
And on the other hand,
the issues of obesity and
some of the other things we talked about.
Yes, if you want to be a responsible
company and you're in that business,
you then also have to be
co-responsible to finding solutions
to these issues that show up
in your total value chain.
I think that the divestiture movement or
the financial market is getting
increasingly interested in this agenda.
We had in Paris at the COP 21,
$24 trillion of capital and
the management asking for
a price on carbon.
We thought in Paris that we could
get the divestiture movement,
the carbon divestiture.
You see a lot of that at universities
now as your endowment funds, etc.
We thought we could get to 100 billion.
We actually got 900 billion
at the time of Paris, and
that number has gone up
to 2.7 trillion now.
So the financial market is catching on.
And you can see that 57 companies in
the US have gone bankrupt that were
in the coal business, Peabody the last
one, just in the last two years alone.
You can see it in other things.
Tesla makes actually relatively few cars,
their Model 3, tremendously popular,
325,000 orders for
that car in the first few days alone.
Despite selling less than one-twenties or
one-thirties of the cars of
General Motors, it has already half
the market cap of General Motors.
Increasingly, the financial
community is folding with the and
they're getting actively involved as
they see this as an enormous risk, but
also an enormous opportunity.
Investment in green energy right now
is far exceeding the investment in
fossil fuel, even with the low
prices in fact that we have.
Now let me pick up pace and do only one or
two more things before we
open it up to Q and As.
I think the first one is the millennials
because there are many millennials in
the audience, and
I would just say that a purpose-driven
business model makes a lot more sense.
Only 30% of millennials actually
want to work for corporates.
They just don't feel it's cool
anymore to work for corporates, for
the reasons that we mentioned.
Since we moved to this much more
stronger purpose doing business model.
We actually find ourselves to
be the third most looked up
company in LinkedIn after Google and
Apple.
Not even being a product name you know,
Lever is sort of the holding name and
all of our products have different names.
We had, at one point, 8 million people
applying to our company every year.
And in most countries that we operate,
we're the preferred employers.
So even from that point of view, it makes
sense to be able to attract the best and
brightest.
Would certainly guarantee
a future of your company.
What we also see clearly is,
that millennials don't want
to just be part of this.
They very much understand that the next 15
years are going to be crucial for them.
They want to be an active
part in shaping this future.
I had the pressure to be serving
on the high level panel,
to develop these sustainable development
goals for the secretary general.
And we put this website out there,
The World We Want.
And within a nanosecond,
we had over a million young people, many
from Africa, writing down what they want.
They want to be actively involved in
shaping this agenda and too often,
we still exclude this young generation.
Next to the millennials, we also obviously
need a different type of leadership.
I was very excited to hear
that here at Stanford,
you're actually trying to put this
curriculum together for a future leaders.
And that you have a first coming home
with the young global leaders
from developed economic forum.
That's a very exciting step
you are talking there, but
it is very clear that the leaders of
tomorrow need to be purpose driven.
Need to be able to work in partnership.
Need to feel comfortable with
that level of transparency.
Need to be systemic thinkers to be
able to handle this complexity, but
above all, need to be human beings.
Human beings with a high level
of awareness and engagement and
a certain level of humanity and humility.
If we get more of these leaders,
and we're clearly short of it now,
looking at the average tenure of a CEO.
But if we get more of these leaders,
I think that we're on the right path
to solve some of these
key issues that we have.
So in conclusion, I think we are,
we should not feel despair.
I think we're moving in the right
direction, but the challenge is obviously,
how fast we move.
Because the longer we wait, the more
difficult the challenge will be or
the more expensive it will be.
But for me, the reason to move fast is,
the longer we wait,
the more people will live in poverty.
And there's no excuse
that we let that happen.
I've always felt that if you belong to the
2% of the world population that can do and
like what they want.
Go to wonderful institutions like this,
find a job they like or work.
Don't have to worry about their child not
making the age of five or being stunted.
Or being included in the workforce and
all the other things.
If you belong to those 2%,
then it's obviously your obligation
to work for the other 98%.
And that is what we're
trying to do in Unilever.
It was Martin Luther King
that actually said,
that everyone can be great
because everyone can serve.
And all of us in our own humble
ways can make the difference to
together create a better world for all.
And certainly for
generations to come and that's
obviously the world I want to live in.
And I want to be part of
that challenge to say,
this is what we really did
in the coming 15 years.
So that nobody else has to
worry about these challenges.
Unlike the Dalai Lama,
one of the things the Dalai Lama said that
If you seek enlightenment for yourself.
Simply to enhance yourself and
your position, you miss purpose,
but if you seek enlightenment for
yourself to enable to serve others.
You are with purpose, so my message to
you very simply is, go with purpose.
Thank you very much.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Well Paul, thank you so
much for those inspiring words.
I think you've left us with
many things to think about,
but there were some
exciting things you said.
There are signs that governments,
companies,
people in general are normally
more aware for taking action.
To do something about the development
agenda about sustainability.
But that was not really
the case a few years back
when you took over Unilever as CEO.
And you came in first day and
made huge changes.
How did you handle all of the challenges
and the resistance that came with that?
>> Well, there were changes indeed,
but first of all,
there was a burning platform and
in fact, I had two of them.
I came in from the outside, which
helped a little by not being so biased.
I thought some of the changes
that needed to be made perhaps.
But the business was not doing so well, so
that was a burning platform and
then you had the crisis in the 2007, 2008.
And so,
it wasn't difficult to convince people
that we needed to do things differently.
Because I came in from the outside and
actually,
I had worked what some people
thought was competition in the past.
I don't have that concept myself,
but some people felt that the Trojan
horse was let into the company.
And I discovered very
early on that it was for
me to prove that I could
be part of the team.
Instead of them to prove that
they could be part of my team.
And I had to establish myself, so
I spent an enormous amount of time
digging into the history of the company.
Jim Collins, in his book,
>From Good to Great,
talks about nurturing the core
before you stimulate progress.
And we actually went back to
the roots of this company.
We actually went to Port Sunlight,
which is in the north of England
where the company had started.
Symbolically had a meeting there
with our senior management and
discussed a little what
made this company great.
And we came to some enormous values and
one of them is certainly
doing well by doing good.
This was a man by the way that,
instituted in the UK the six
hour day was very revolutionary
in the 1800s I can tell you.
When he became a Lord and
he went into parliament,
he introduced the pension plans.
When his employees would go to war,
volunteer for
the wars that would add a World War I and
World War II.
He obviously dealt only with World War I,
but guaranteed the wages to the wives so
that they could live in.
So, he was next to ordinary
man in that sense.
But always have to believe what
doing well by doing good funding.
The marines he would ship off
sustainable fishery at a round
table of sustainable development.
So what we did is,
we took all that strength and said,
can we not turn it into a business model
that is desperately needed right now?
Where we link all of this, and
see this as an increasingly, powerful
driver for future business growth.
And what the surprise in all of this,
it's hard work.
It's not that easy obviously, and
some people are always skeptical but
you need them to make better plans.
But people rally quite
quickly towards something,
when it is a higher purpose and
want to be part of that.
People want to make a difference,
they want to live as well in a little bit
better place,
they want to touch people positively.
And if you can work for a company that,
where those values can come alive,
then people feel happier.
And you've seen it in
our engagement scores,
which were sort of in the bottom
side when we started.
And now, they're off the map,
because people want to be part of this.
>> On that note, can you tell us,
when did you find purpose in promoting
sustainability as a business practice?
Well, the question is always,
why didn't our predecessors deal with
this as much as they should have.
And the answer is,
really the issue wasn't so evident.
Because we've lifted so
many people out of poverty,
we really got the issues
of planetary boundaries.
If you go back, even at the time that the
original millennial development goals were
developed.
The word sustainable
didn't show up there even.
There were issues of HIV.
There were issues in
the developing markets.
Now many of these issues
have become global,
because of our inter dependent wealth.
So, it's only in the last 10 years
that people have become fully aware of
what needed to be changed.
That's why you see this momentum now,
but I would not worry about that.
We now have to do is to be sure that
we can accelerate, because as usual,
there's always a little bit of vested
order that doesn't like to change.
If you're on the right side of the
equation in this transformation of this
global economy.
You are more likely to be resistant,
than if you are not cutting
the benefits on the global economy.
But the reality right now is, about 99% of
the people are not getting the benefits of
the global economy anymore.
So, I hope we can build this momentum and
accelerate that to make the changes.
By the way, nothing to do with
being Democrat or Republican or
being a Dutchman often
accused of smoking pot.
And all the other thing,s [LAUGH]
which is liberalized in our country.
And it just has to do with a common
sense agenda to make this world work for
all of us long term.
If you see the cost that Europe now has
on refugees, for example, it's enormous.
And then,
you see the money that we spent is
a pittance to actually solve these issues.
So it's becoming increasingly transparent,
I think,
that this is an agenda for humanity.
>> The way you frame things to me,
it sounds like today,
there's also a momentum.
And today,
we are still at an inflection point
companies could use to
change business practices.
And yet, you don't see those that do
stand out, because not many are doing it.
What is that?
>> And that's a good question.
That's a good question.
I start from the premise that I
believe in the goodness of people.
Because I never met a CEO who wants more
unemployment or more climate change or
more pollution.
Unless they don't tell me, but
I don't think they are there really, so
you have to believe in
the goodness of all of us.
And then, you have to ask
yourself the question, well,
if that is the case,
why doesn't it happen?
And there are obviously many reasons for
that.
The global economy isn't functioning,
so you have to work very hard to
even keep your own company afloat.
These issues of tenure,
that you might not have the skill sets, so
there are many of those reasons.
But I think in essence, it boils down to,
the behavior of people ss
governed by the boundaries in which you
operate and that is true for all of us.
If you have become a father or
a mother and you have children.
You start to think of different boundaries
and you have different behaviors.
You might not go out to the bar every
night anymore with your buddies.
You might want to do a little
bit more babysitting or
sit together with your kids.
If I tell a salesman that he gets rewarded
on the number of orders he writes.
Sales orders, he's going to split many
orders and write a lot of orders.
If I tell him he's going to be rewarded
on the total sales volume he brings in,
he might have a different behavior.
And there are three main things in this
world that drive people's behavior in
a dysfunctional way.
The first one is the short
term versus long term, so
we have to move the market
to the longer term.
Larry Fink who runs the BlackRock,
one of the biggest institutions.
Has written about that, because everybody
sees this destructiveness of that.
The second thing is this
balance between man and nature.
We have put the boundaries wrong.
If you again and again,
not that I want to be religious here,
but if you go to the book of Genesis,
it says mans dominance over nature.
And we have started to interpret that a,s
that we can literally dominate nature and
destroy nature.
That we are smarter, but our intelligence
was meant to be stewards of nature.
So we have to give nature
a value in all we do and
we need to move the narrow
definition of GDP.
Or the profit and loss statement in
a company to more integrated reporting.
Including, the environmental and social
capital next to the financial capital.
Capitalists are very good
at optimizing capital, but
we've only put them on the paths
to optimize financial capital.
But if we put a price on carbon,
for example, we would move much faster
in bringing climate change down.
Just like you put a price on the water,
we bring water uses down.
So move to environmental and
social accounting, next to financial,
is absolutely a must.
And then the third element of the
boundaries is really our financial system.
Our financial system's rewards are all on
capital and unfortunately, not on labor.
Because they were designed
at a different time, but
we have been slow at evolving it.
One of the reasons that we've
been slow at evolving is,
that most of the institutions that we
have created at the time of Breton Woods.
Which was a long time ago for
you, in the 40s, but
it was when 90% or 85% of the world
economy was in Europe and the US.
Now, we have a global economy and
it's interdependent and
we haven't figured out yet,
how to create the institutions to rule it.
And we need to move to a system
where we don't reward capital.
You take this country,
I was in New York on Monday and
Tuesday, a few hedge funds guys,
and I'm not against them.
But a few hedge funds guys last
year together made ten billion.
That tax rate probably is 10%.
Then they give 25 million to charity
to help the homeless in New York and
they're heroes.
They're all of a sudden
philanthropists of the highest order.
they probably use the 25 million to
offset their taxable on the 10%,
and but they created
the problem in the first place.
Because our system,
we watch the capital at no tax and
the people that work and
labor often catch 40, 50% tax.
At the time that we need to create more
jobs, we need to subsidize labor and
penalize capital,
because we have enough of the capital.
We don't need to get higher returns.
Now, I think that’s very radical thought
for some people in the U.S., but
it’s absolutely needed if we want
to change the global economy.
>> My gosh.
After that answer, I have so
many questions about what you think of tax
systems, supply chains,
governments, world thought leaders.
But I'm going to take a pause right now
and allow the audience to make a question.
There is going to be
a microphone over here and
do we have a microphone
in the back as well?
Okay.
So we have a question right here.
If you can just stand up, say your name,
and ask one question please.
>> Well thank you for an inspiring talk.
You talked about supply chains,
supply chains and
there are a lot of CEOs in that.
Can you talk about
sustainable consumption?
So, how do we move people away from,
let's say, buying more cars.
We're looking at penetration of
electric cars right now in the market.
But have you thought about
where are we going to
dispose of batteries in the next 30,
40 years?
>> Well, one of the things that people
are starting to think about, obviously,
is to move from this linear economy.
That I briefly referred to
as this circular economy.
Right now, we're basically digging
it out of the ground, producing, and
then dumping it again.
And if we keep digging, you end up in
Australia and there's not much left,
and that's really what we are doing.
So how can you be sure that someone
else's waste is someone else's input, so
that nothing goes to waste?
So at Unilever, we for example said,
we want to run all of our 500 plus
factories that we have at zero waste.
we actually achieved that
two years ahead of target
by thinking about it differently.
Our cost goes down, the pride goes up,
quality goes up actually.
Customer service goes up.
There's a lot of benefits from doing that.
So, the circular economy concept thinks
about moving into that direction.
It's very exciting with
Millenials actually.
They are not as possessive as we were.
They really are growing
up in a sharing economy.
Uber, AirBnB are the examples of that.
But increasingly the feel very
comfortable by paying for experiences,
but not paying for physical goods.
So that goes in to the right direction.
But having said that,
it needs obviously much more.
So in Europe now, there's a directive
on century economy coming in.
Many countries in the world don't
have waste recycling systems yet.
And it's difficult for
countries to do or start sometimes, but
if you have a country like India or Brazil
or China not having waste recycling,
then Houston we have a problem.
So, we've put the global consumer goods
industry for example, together to,
because no company can do it alone,
to move into some of that, in targeting
country by country for example, to move
to recycling systems and other things.
And at the end of the day,
we need to, which is very hard for
companies to understand, we need to
stimulate consumers to use less.
And people might say,
why would you advocate that as a company?
Because there is a big difference
between using less material and
creating more value.
I can create far more
value with less material.
But you have to think about that.
So, we look at all of our products, for
example, do complections,
do lightweighting on plastics.
Be sure that actually the products
leave from what's in the bottle because
In many products, 15-20% stays in
the bottle when you throw it away.
And as we do all of these things you
actually get higher customer satisfaction.
Create relations so
as consumers you can build value of.
So you have to indeed think about
a gross model without using more stuff.
But creating more value
in its broadest sense.
And those models are actually
very successful.
You take food and food in the US
has always been driven by calories.
You would go to one of these pizza places,
and I'm victim of it
myself with my three boys.
I could go to Pizza Hut, and
as a European I could never understand it
because I brought in two or three coupons.
And I would leave with money and
five pizzas.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So,
I never understood how the system worked.
But this was the American dream, I guess.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But, it was all based on calories.
And it was, the lower the better,
the more we could get calories.
And that gave a certain
level of happiness, I guess.
Now, you see in the food industry in the
United States rapidly moving to nutrition.
People are willing to pay more for
less excess.
I would go to a restaurant where I get a
half a plate, I would actually pay more so
that I don't have to see all
that stuff I can't eat anyway or
feel very bad that it's
thrown away afterwards.
I actually pay more for it now.
And I think that's happening in
the global economy in total.
So, that notion of that a little
bit more purpose driven and
more conscious sharing is creeping up.
>> Paul, in these last two
minutes that we have with you,
could you share some advice?
Most of us here are MBA students
looking to go back in to.
For profit organizations and will probably
not be the CEO right off the start,
so-
>> You might.
[LAUGH]
>> Thank you.
What can we do To
bring sustainable practices into
the organizations we're going to.
>> Yeah, first of all don't have
an ambition to become a CEO that this is
a stupid ambition.
I always tell people not because
I don't like my job, but
it's just anybody can have that title.
The most important thing is
that you pursue your purpose.
Whatever you feel strong about.
If you figure out where you
want to make the difference,
that's the first thing you need to do.
Some might fight for women's rights,
some might have to fight for
people in emerging markets, some might
want to include better education.
But, you need to have something that
you want to have an impact in, as well.
And that has to align with your values.
If that aligns with your values,
you are going to be successful
because it will drive your passion.
Doesn't matter, the money you earn is
not an indicator of success anymore.
People's self-worth should not be
measured by people's net worth.
It's very important if you
want to have a good life.
And then the third thing is
obviously a positive attitude
is equally important because the things
never go the way you want them to go.
Otherwise, someone else would
have done it before you.
So the road to change is a road
that has many skeptics or
cynics, rejections, but if you
are strongly driven by your purpose and
your values I think, and the stronger
they are, the better beacon you have,
in a very volatile environment,
to deal with these challenges.
You stay guided as someone once said,
by the lights of the stars,
not by the lights of the passing ships.
And at the end of the day,
you need to do what you really feel you
can make the biggest difference, if you're
in a unfortunate position like ours.
I don't say it on camera but
the reason I work in this company and
give my energy to that is because I can
have a bigger impact in doing what I do
now than I can see in any other
opportunity that is offered to me.
And if that is a possibility to have
a bigger impact to change the world for
the better, then that's my duty to do.
Until someone else can
do it better than I do.
And the final point I just want
to leave you is the importance of
a positive attitude.
Reminds me of a story that my father
always taught me of the boiling water
with the carob, the egg and
the coffee bean.
And the act is actually very soft.
But it goes into the boiling water and
becomes very hard and stubborn.
You can't do anything with it.
The carrot was actually strong.
Went in to the boiling water,
but became very soft and mushy.
But the coffee bean
went into the water and
changed the colour of the water around it.
But state the coffee bean.
So, my message to all of you is
just be the coffee bean in life.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Everyone a big round of applause for
Paul Coleman please.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]